So the big idea in this lesson was to do
a BFS by recasting it in matrix terms.
You did so
in order to reuse your basic ideas
from distributing matrix operations.
This is a really neat connection,
and you can take it even further.
Now it might not always work,
or work as well.
So, here's a fun exercise
to do at this point.
Go read about or review other
kinds of graph computations.
Then ask whether you can do the same
sort of mapping from graphs to matrices.
For instance,
is there a matrix based way to do
a Depth first search as opposed
to a breadth first search?
What about all pairs shortest paths?
Triangle counting?
Computing betweeness centrality?
Maybe others.